herzlich willkommen zu einem ganz ganz
besonderen Video heute wird ein
Sternekoch gegen eine künstliche
Intelligenz antreten wir werden sehen
wie gut ein Computer denken kann wie ein
Koch handeln kann wie ein Koch es ist
verdammt spannend und ich freue mich
meine Gäste für heute begrüßen zu dürfen
einmal Max wieder Lorenz ich glaube ihr
kennt ihn mittlerweile alle schön dass
du da bist und auf der anderen Seite für
die künstliche Intelligenz Kasper hübsch
beide verdammt gute Köche ihr von beiden
schon das Essen hier auf dem Kanal
gesehen und casper hat sich zur
Verfügung gestellt seine handwerklichen
Skills seine Fähigkeiten zu geben für
die künstliche Intelligenz hier drüben
steht der Laptop der uns heute alles aus
der Hand nehmen wird der uns sagen wird
wie Casper kochen soll und ich bin
verdammt aufgeregt hier sind die Zutaten
gehen wir einmal in den Front rein das
sind die Zutaten die wir haben Seeteufel
Jakobsmuscheln Auberginen shiitake Pilze
Romana Salat Knollensellerie Kalamata
Oliven Zitronengras Estragon Zitrone
Orangen Pistazien getrocknete Feigen
sesamkartoffeln Frühlingszwiebeln
Limette Ingwer Knoblauch Zwiebel
Rosmarin mit Minze die Aufgaben Trennung
lautet wie folgt erstelle mir ein
gourmetrezept ich bin gourmet-chef
arbeite seit 20 Jahren in der
Sternegastronomie es müssen nicht alle
Produkte verwendet werden ich trete
gegen einen Sternekoch an hier ist ein
anspruchsvolles und kreatives
gourmetrezept für dich gegrillter
Seeteufel mit Shiitake Pilzen
Zitronengras Ingwer Emulsion und
Kartoffel Romanasalat ja max ich würde
sagen du hast im Moment Zeit guck dir
die Zutaten an und Verrat uns den Titel
von deiner Kreation wir werden eine
gebratenen Seeteufel in einer leichten
pistazienmantel machen dazu ein Tartar
von Jakobsmuscheln Ingwer abgerundet
wird das mit einem leichten Aufguss von
Zitronengras gegrillte shiitake Pilze
die grillten Römersalat gepickelte
Zwiebeln und eine leichte
zitronensellerie Creme ich würde sagen
the games on stimmt euch ab wie lange
wir das ganze machen und dann geht's los
das klingt zu will
ich gehe da die Kamera macht euer Ding
ich stelle hier das Rezept bereit ja was
ist dein erster Eindruck zum Rezept bin
gespannt wie das wenn der Umsetzung
stattfinden wird dazu habe ich ja auf
jeden Fall die Zubereitung die mir jetzt
auch durchlesen darf wird einfach heute
der KI entsprechen und versuchen das
ordentlich umzusetzen ich bin ready
let's go die ersten Minuten sind
vergangen wie immer hat Maximilian
Lorenz schon sein Rezept fast fertig
was ist deine erste Reaktion auf das
Rezept so richtig wohl fühl ich mich
damit auf jeden Fall noch nicht ja es
ist auf jeden Fall ein Vorteil dass er
direkt starten kann weil er weiß was er
macht und ich muss erstmal reingehen und
gucken was ich überhaupt tun muss weil
ich muss mich ja komplett danach richten
aber ich denke ich arbeite jetzt einfach
mal nach Liste und mach eins nach dem
anderen und dann werden wir schon
Vorankommen wie fühlst du dich magst du
das wird also ich glaube ein bisschen
kochen kann nicht ich bin sehr
optimistisch ich glaube die ganzen
Produkte die quasi hier sind schmeicheln
alle den Fisch sind alles Smart das ist
alles cool das muss man ja auch sein wie
Rezepte kommen auch oder die
Zutatenliste kommt auch von der KI also
diese Abstimmung und sowas ist nicht von
uns sondern da hat die KI auf jeden Fall
schon mal performt du musst dich jetzt
natürlich hier tatsächlich
noch länger dann für die Zitronengras
Ingwer Emulsion muss man nämlich
habt ihr das gesehen Leute um so zu
schneiden braucht man auf jeden Fall ein
scharfes Messer und das geht natürlich
nicht nur in der Küche das MSI Katana 17
ist das fortschrittlichste Werkzeug von
morgen auf dem wir heute die KI laufen
lassen MSI dürfte vielen von euch einen
Begriff sein da sie einfach eines der
führenden Unternehmen für Gaming Laptops
sind falls nicht hole ich euch kurz ab
von businessgeräten über Mainstream
Gaming hin zu extremer Performance
bietet MSI wirklich für jeden etwas
Wasser ihre Geräte bestätigen durch die
Design ihre Langlebigkeit und vor allem
ihre verarbeitet wer mich wirklich kennt
weiß dass ich gerne mal mit meinen Jungs
abends Fortnite Spiele und dafür ist das
MSI Katana 17 wirklich perfekt mit
seiner GeForce RTX 40 von Nvidia und
seinem Intel Core i7 Prozessor der 13
Generation ist er perfekt ausgestattet
mit diesen Hardware Komponenten sind
auch triple A Titel wie Cyberpunk
problemlos möglich das Katana 17 kann
aber auch perfekt umgehen mit Office
Anwendung wie zum Beispiel Excel oder
Bildbearbeitung Video Bearbeitung wie
ich es auch täglich nutze die Geräte von
MSI sind vielseitige Werkzeuge weil sie
alle Komponenten in einem Verein
außerdem besteht das Katana 17 mit einem
kompakten und portablen Design und
bestätigt durch modernste Komponenten
schaut euch also gerne die MSI Produkte
im ersten Link unter dem Video an vielen
Dank an MSI für die Unterstützung weiter
geht's in der Küche
[Musik]
es riecht interessant auf jeden Fall ne
man bildet sich also ein bisschen
schärfer schon zu riechen von dem lieben
Öl also ich würde für die Emotionen
Olivenöl wahrscheinlich nicht in so
einem hochleistungsmixer so sehr mixen
das könnte bitter werden aber da die
eines möchte machen wir das heute also
als Zuschauer ist es gerade übelster wir
wahr aber bei dir im Kopf ist
wahrscheinlich alles voll geplant bei
mir im Kopf geplant ist aber ich hatte
am Anfang gesagt so was ich was ich
kochen möchte kann sich das schon
geändert
auf jeden Fall sagen muss es Max dass du
glaube ich eine ordentliche Fallhöhe
hast wenn du jetzt plötzlich ersetzt
wirst und ich sage dir gar nicht ich mag
dich ich werde am Ende ehrlich bewerten
also wenn mir das KI Gericht brutal gut
schmeckt und deins nicht ganz so brutal
und dann sage ich das deshalb ich bin
gespannt wie das heute wird du hast
wirklich was zu verlieren ich bin ja ja
wie Erik unterwegs
aber natürlich ne ich bin nicht
angetreten zum Verlieren ich merke
wirklich wie krass war eigentlich am
liebsten auch kreativ kochen würde und
immer also gezwungen wird auch das
Rezept zu schauen ich glaube wenn man
richtig gut kochen kann ist das
wahrscheinlich nicht ich finde es gerade
einfach extrem spannend euch beiden
zuzuschauen wie ihr auch einfach dieses
Handwerk ausübt das Schneiden das
Begutachten der verschiedenen
Komponenten das ist einfach so wie
schnell das vonstatten geht und ich
finde genau das ist eine Sache die so
schnell auch keine KI übernehmen kann so
kochen bleibt ein Handwerk und in der
Komplexität mit den verschiedenen
Zutaten umzugehen da kann man vielleicht
ein gutes Rezept bekommen aber im Kopf
kann so schnell glaube ich niemand
ersetzen ich werde immer Wärme mit dem
Gericht vorgeschlagen bekommen habe also
da komme ich zurecht ich habe langsam
mittlerweile Überblick was ich alles
noch tun muss und das auch gar nicht
mehr so viel ist aber ich versuche jetzt
einfach im Detail das Gut abzuschmecken
weil das ist das einzige was ich heute
machen kann ne schönen anzurichten
gerade machst einfach gut aussehen das
sieht super farbenfroh und einfach
Frische und lecker aus was ist das ich
habe einfach
ein bisschen Oliven klein gehackt
Zitronenabrieb Orangenabrieb ganz grob
gehacktes Estragon mit rein Olivenöl
Zitronensaft Salz und quasi kommt es aus
der mediterranen Küche wenn es die
Remoulade das wird hauptsächlich mit
Petersilie hergestellt und ist sowas ja
wie ein grobes fest und bisschen
spicycer du schüttest jetzt die Milch
vom Püree mit in diese Butter genau so
quasi meine Soße ich habe jetzt hier
quasi mit Mehlschwitze gezogen
abgelöscht ich werde gleich einmal
passieren wenn ich Musik bekomme hier
die Pilze wäre die Videos von Max kennt
ohne Flüssigkeit und ohne Öl in die
Pfanne mitgeben wenn man will kann man
noch ein bisschen Salz dazugeben die
Pilze noch mal ein bisschen sorgt für
Flüssigkeitsverlust und dann geht die
Sache noch besser durch der Großteil ist
es warten auf die Kartoffeln und später
der Situation am Ende erst mit dem
Anrichten also ich glaube das wird dann
erst später sein ich freue mich dass ich
heute einfach nur zuschauen darf man
merkt schon dass das Arbeiten und das
ist auch komisch kein kein normales
Kochen ich muss sagen langsam fühlt sich
die Küche ja auch mit Düften kann ich
bei euch mal was probieren was haben wir
hier haben wir diesen Zitronengras sucht
wo wir quasi die Reste von dem Püree
verarbeitet hatten was wir schaffen und
du bist immer noch hier am emulgieren
gerade
ein bisschen mehr abzuschmecken die ist
noch nicht final wo wir gerne mal wir
haben hier eine schöne Säure und auf
jeden Fall eine exotische Geschichte mit
der Zitrone und dem Zitronengras woW ist
auf jeden Fall eine coole Sache auch
solide die Bitterstoffe die machen sich
gerade ganz gut schmeckt das noch Finale
ab und das wird halt später die Soße
sein das heißt mal gucken wo wir damit
hinkommen ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
das so intensiv die verschiedenen
Bestandteile greifen echt gut ineinander
ja das kann wahrscheinlich gut einfach
die Dinge zu finden die gut zueinander
passen und die zusammen zu schmeißen ich
habe das muss man schon mal sagen das
funktioniert gerade eben habe ich
wirklich gedacht das wird sehr sehr
einseitig aber also das schmeckt
wirklich
bist du schon am Ende oder was
vielleicht schon okay ja das heißt ich
würde noch mal 15 Minuten maximal geben
okay und dann bin ich aber auch schon
fast bereit würde ich sagen bzw
du kannst gut aussehen jetzt noch ein
bisschen ne und
das erste Mensch
nein er hat ein ganz einfachen Grund
geschmacksintensiviert karamellisieren
wir die an oh normalerweise ist jetzt ja
die Zitrone einfach frisch zum frisch
und jetzt karamellisiert sie wunderschön
wird halt süß sauer bringt halt direkt
so ein Gewissen mit rein und fürs
anrichten wunderschön ne das ist schon
smart und da kommt halt die KI auch
nicht drauf ne die probiert ja möglichst
häufig genannt Dinge die erwiesenermaßen
funktionieren wiederzugeben und hier
haben wir halt wirklich Nischen Dingen
was aber verdammt also ich bin jetzt
auch gerade beim Kühlschrank gekommen
und ich habe gesehen ich darf nicht mal
groß Butter oder sowas verwenden
normalerweise würde ich den erst auf der
einen Seite braten umdrehen und dazu
Knoblauch Thymian und so weiter und der
ganzen Sache immer einen schönen
Geschmack geben das darf ich jetzt hier
nicht dementsprechend werde ich hoffen
dass ich mit Salz und Pfeffer da genug
Geschmack ankriegen was sagt denn die KI
was du machen sollst die sagt
tatsächlich dass ich den Salz und
pfeffern soll vor dem braten und dann
gleichzeitig gar braten soll da ist ja
auch ein dehnbarer Begriff ich werde das
mit der Temperatur schon kontrollieren
und den nicht komplett tot braten und
das ist meine Freiheit dann denke ich
aber ansonsten müssen wir auch hier
gucken ja ich bin fertig bei mir ich bin
ich gehe jetzt meine Rauchen ja ich muss
mich ans Rezept halten dementsprechend
wie gesagt wir sind die Hände gebunden
ich gehe bei der Gas und wir gucken
mit dem Kochen sollte ich mal beruflich
überlegen das ist vielleicht was werden
Kraft weil ich auftreten aber dennoch
sorry
langsam beginnen hier die finalen
Schritte die beiden sind so gut wie
fertig und die Gerichte könnten
unterschiedlich ja nicht aussehen
zumindest die Vorbereitung jetzt wird
gebraten genau
Holz zur Konzentration kurz vor der Züge
an Final Countdown
habe ich einfach das Herz vom frischen
Lauch geguckt dann die großen
römersalatblätter habe ich einfach auch
mit rein so dann ein bisschen
schmackofatz Kochen ne Knoblauch mit
Schale mit Schale einfach alles drin
stell mir gerade einfach nur so egal was
ich hier jetzt machen würde es würde
mich halt so gut aussehen
Knoblauch dran gemacht jawoll aber das
darf ich auch noch Rezept ja eine
Komponenten auch langsam anderes drin
genau ein bisschen angebraten mit Salz
ab 14 kommen noch dazu genau einfach ein
bisschen für die Farbe dieses ganze Fett
was ja jetzt entsteht ne das soll die
Nuss aufziehen das gehen wir nachher
noch so ein bisschen über den Fisch
drüber das ist auch sehr unfair das
klingt einfach schon zu gut ich glaube
so wenig wie in den letzten 5 Minuten
wurde heute noch nicht geredet bei allen
ist jetzt Konzentration auf 100 % und
der Fisch wird gar gezogen an
richtstation werden gebaut und ich
glaube jetzt können wir zusehen wie die
beiden das Gericht finalisieren
[Musik]
hier sitzen jetzt also vor zwei wirklich
hübschen Gerichten und ihr könnt ja
vielleicht einfach noch mal sagen was
das Ganze ist wie bezeichnest du deine
Kreation also wir haben dann quasi den
Seeteufel und unter gerösteten Pistazien
mit Gegrilltem Romanasalat nach
selleriecreme einem kleinen Tartar von
Jakobsmuscheln und Ingwer bisschen
gebraten ist saisonales Gemüse eine
selleriecreme und eine Soße angelehnt
alle Tom kha Gai mit dem Koch such von
Sellerie also wir das kann ich direkt
hier Vorlesen aus der KI wir haben den
gegrillten Seeteufel mit Shiitake Pilzen
Zitronengras Ingwer Emulsion und
Kartoffeln Romanasalat ich muss eine
Sache Glas klarstellen Kasper ist ein
riesiger Ehrenmann dass er das heute
gemacht hat weil ich habe gemerkt wie er
darunter gelitten hat nicht seine
Kreativität sein Skill sein Know-how in
das Gericht einfließen zu lassen deshalb
wisst das auf jeden Fall hier hat nicht
Kasper gekauft sondern die KI und casper
hat sich quasi in die Dienste der KI
gestellt das will ich sagen und jetzt
will ich probieren ich glaube ich fange
an mit seinem Gericht Kasper die
Portionsgröße fällt im Kontrast auf auf
jeden Fall stark auf weil die KI
scheinbar gedacht hat wir machen viel
Gang Menü irgendwie ne hat auf jeden
Fall nur ein Gericht ausgespuckt das ist
eher klein geworden aber also was ich
dazwischen durch schon mal probiert habe
war auf jeden Fall echt lecker ich
probiere erstmal shiitake Pilze mit
Frühlingszwiebeln
kann mir jetzt schon vorstellen dass sie
sehr gut zum Fisch passen werden
vielleicht weil die auch so beieinander
liegen aber geschmacklich ist das auf
jeden Fall schon oder auch optisch ist
das etwas wo man sich denken würde
könnten Mensch auf jeden Fall gekocht
haben und auch einer der wirklich weiß
wie man kocht soweit so beeindruckend
gehen wir mal in den Fisch rein
wunderschönen glasig sieht richtig gut
aus also da merkt man natürlich dann das
kostbar am Werk war und nicht die KI
selbst ich gehe damit mal rein in diese
zitrusoße die wunderschöne herunter Kopf
und okay also Zitrusnote ist da das
Olivenöl schmeckt man definitiv auch das
ist nicht perfekt in die Soße
übergegangen aber alles in allem auch
mit diesem ich nenne es jetzt mal
Kartoffelsalat heißt das auch
Kartoffelsalat Kartoffelsaft das ist
schon echt eine sehr sehr sehr sehr gute
Kreation also wenn ich das alles so in
dem Mauer bekommen würde dann wäre es
definitiv nicht das letzte Mal dass ich
in diesem Restaurant gegessen hätte also
das ist schon echt gut wir haben schönen
sommerlich frisch also wirklich ein
leckeres Gericht ich würde dem aus dem
Bauch heraus eine gute Art von 10 geben
das hier sieht schon heftig aus weiß ich
nicht ich habe doch ein bisschen was
zusammen also Casper wie gerne hättest
Du in seiner Haut gesteckt und heute
kreativ gekocht also jetzt und gerade
auch beim Kochen gerade eben weil ich
ziemlich neidisch muss ich sagen das
muss einfach so frei ausleben kann dass
man ich habe jetzt z.B ein Romana Salat
einfach in Kartoffelsalat drin er hat
jetzt die Möglichkeit die verschiedenen
Facetten vom Romana Salat zu nutzen
wollte auch immer mal wieder so
irgendwas machen und so wir haben direkt
so gesagt nein du darfst nicht die
karamellisierte Zitrone nämlich einfach
mal und Teufel etwas über den Fisch und
über den Rest auch hier wieder eine
schöne Idee kreativ gelöst ich meine
dass du am Anfang als du dein Gericht
genannt hast da war da noch nicht die
karamellisierung
einfach sagen wir gehen über ein
Wochenmarkt kaufen uns am anfangstück
Fisch dann gehen wir zurück auf uns noch
eine Garnele dann vielleicht eine
Kartoffel eine Kartoffel machen wir
morgen eigentlich vor die Paprika heute
Abend und dann stehst du in der Küche
und denkst okay heute mache ich daraus
vielleicht ein paar Elia und nachher ist
es in Sashimi geworden als crunchy Roll
und dann hatte ich viel mehr Bock drauf
und ich glaube KI kann Denkanstöße geben
fürs Kochen aber sie kann und das hoffe
ich das Beweis dass Gericht nicht diese
cucina dieses Herz diese Emotionen
verbinden das ist interessant probieren
wir jetzt das Gericht von Max Lorenz auf
jeden Fall jetzt schon sehr vielfältiger
Löffel und ich probiere
boah das ist wirklich wieder so eine
geschmackliche Breitseite wo man süße
Säure Cremigkeit und auch ganz viele
geschmackskassetten die man so noch gar
nicht kennt hat also es ist wirklich
total Fisch das unterstützt auf jeden
Fall noch mal die Rest darum mit der
Pistazie und so ich glaube es steht kein
Gewinner fest sondern ein Verlierer und
der Verlierer ist heute die KI weil
weder Kasper noch max haben verloren es
ist ein
deutiger Sieg für die Kreativität für
die Vielfältigkeit die Küche wirklich
leben und das Kochen ausmacht das hier
ist Kunst und das hier sind Zahlen
deshalb wirklich Respekt und ein großes
Dankeschön an euch beide dass ihr damit
gemacht habt ich glaube ihr wollt und
dürft unbedingt auch alles probieren
wirklich alles ja spannendsten und
besten Videos finde
raus und Check die beiden ab danke Ciao
geil Alter